SURE THEY'RE WATCHING.
>> Sean: BEST TO BOTH OF THEM.
JOINING ME, THE GOP U.S. SENATE
CANDIDATE FROM MICHIGAN, JOHN
JAMES, IS WITH US.
TURNING POINT USA COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR, OUR FRIEND CANDACE
OWENS.
CANDACE WAS WITH KANYE IN D.C.
EARLIER TODAY.
YOU ACTUALLY FACILITATED A PHONE
CALL WITH ME AND KANYE.
AND IT WASN'T -- WE FACE TIMED.
WHAT I REALLY LIKED ABOUT IT,
ALL HE WANTS IS ANSWERS.
ALL HE WANTS IS SHUGSS.
ALL HE WANTS IS OPPORTUNITIES,
SOLUTIONS.
I AGREE WITH PRISON REFORM, I
WANT MORE MADE IN AMERICA, I
WANT A BETTER ECONOMY AND I WANT
SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS.
WHAT IS THERE TO DISAGREE WITH?
>> THE FACT THAT HE LIKES OUR
PRESIDENT.
THE FACT HAH THAT HE'S BRINGING
FORTH AN OPTIMISTIC MESSAGE.
THE LEFT HAS BECOME THE PARTY OF
HATE AND DIVISION.
KANYE IS TALKING ABOUT LOVE AND
UNITY AND SUPPORT FOR OUR
PRESIDENT WHO IS DOING A
TREMENDOUS JOB.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE REAL NUMBERS
THAT ARE IN.
400% INCREASE IN BLACK GROWTH IN
JOBS AND STARTING BLACK
BUSINESSES.
400% INCREASE.
BLACK UNAPPOINTMENT AT AN
ALL-TIME LOW.
PRESIDENT OBAMA BROUGHT AN
ALL-TIME HIGH FOR WELFARE.
WE HAD PRESIDENT PALESTINIAN
CLINTON BEFORE HIM BROUGHT AN
ALL-TIME HIGH FOR BLACK
INCARCERATION.
WHY ISN'T THE BLACK COMMUNITY
STANDING WITH OUR PRESIDENT
RIGHT NOW?
>> Sean: DID HE SAY HE WAS A
BILLIONAIRE?
>> YES, TLLY FOX NEWS REPORTED
THAT.
>> Sean: HOW AWESOME, TALKING
ABOUT JOBS THAT PAY 50, 60,
70,000 A YEAR.
PEOPLE WOULD LOVE THOSE JOBS.
GET THEM HERE.
JOHN JAMES, I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVIEW ON MY
RADIO SHOW.
I HONESTLY, CAN SAY THIS, ON
RADIO 30 YEARS, HE TOOK MY
BREATH AWAY.
BECAUSE OF YOUR PASSION.
I HOPE THE PEOPLE OF MICHIGAN
ARE GETTING TO KNOW YOU.
I KNOW IT'S A TOUGH STATE TO RUN
FOR SENATE.
I HOPE THE PEOPLE OF MICHIGAN
ARING WHAT I THINK IS A GREAT
MESSAGE TO MAKE MICHIGAN GREAT
AGAIN.
>> PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN ARE ASTUTE.
THIS IS A STATE THAT DONALD
TRUMP WON BUT SO DID BERNIE
SANDERS.
THEY'RE SICK AND TIRED OF BEING
SICK AND TIRED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT 98% OF BLACK
PEOPLE VOTE IN ONE PARTY THAT'S
THE REASON WE DON'T HAVE A SEAT
AT BOTH TABLES.
I'M AN INDEPENDENT THINKER WHO
PRIORITIZES GOD AND COUNTRY IN
THAT ORDER.
I WILL ALWAYS SERVE THE STATE OF
MIF AS WELL AS I SERVE THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WHEN I
DEPLOYED TO OPERATION IRAQIE
FREEDOM.
>> Sean: I WENT THROUGH DETROIT
AND I SAW ONE OF AMERICA'S GREAT
CITIES.
IT WAS DEVASTATING.
IT WAS, I MEAN, SELLING HOMES
FOR A DOLLAR, KNOCKING DOWN
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS TO
CONSOLIDATE BECAUSE OF THE
MANUFACTURING JOBS THAT MOVED
OUT.
NOW JOBS ARE MOVING IN TO AREAS
LIKE MICHIGAN, WISCONSIN, AND
OHIO AND PENNSYLVANIA.
I THINK WE CAN REVITALIZE A CITY
LIKE DETROIT.
AM I DREAMING HERE OR ROOTED IN
REALITY?
>> NO, LOOK, YOU'RE EXACTLY ON
TRACK.
WE KNOW THAT WE CAN REVITALIZE
DETROIT.
THE THING IS, UNTIL THESE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY IMPROOVMS
IMPROVEMENTS COME TO THE PEOPLE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS, FORGOTTEN
NEIGHBORHOODS AND FARMS, THE
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN NEGLECTED
AND FAILED BY DEMOCRAT POLICIES,
DECADES IN THE PAST, WE HAVE
MARCHED FROM SELMA TO DETROIT.
WE HAVE RIOTED FROM BALTIMORE TO
WATTS.
NOTHING HAS CHANGED IN 50 YEARS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T JUST --
>> Sean: FIRST NEIGHBORHOODS
SHOULD BE SAFE.
CHICAGO ISN'T SAFE.
I'D LOVE THE PART PRESIDENT TO
PARTNER WITH KANYE AND COME UP
WITH ANSWERS FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CHICAGO.
IT IS A SHOOTING ZONE.
IT'S HAPPENING FOR YEARS.
NOBODY IS FIXING IT.
>> WE NEED MORE SOLUTION, WE
NEED LEADERSHIP AND LESS
PARTISANSHIP.
YOU CAN LEARN ABOUT MY CANDIDACY
ON JOHNJAMESFORCONGRESS, I HAVE
EXPERIENCE ON THE BATTLEGROUND
TO MAKE THINGS BETTER, BRINGING
EVERYBODY UP.
>> Sean: CANDACE, WHY ARE
PEOPLE, THAT ARE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
CONSERVATIVE BRUTALIZED BY THE
LEFT?
>> BECAUSE TLE DON'T WANT US TO
BE FREE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE THE LEFT DEPENDS
ON THE BLACK VOTE.
THEY HAVE TO EARN MORE THAN 85%
OF THE BLACK VOTE TO SUSTAIN
THEIR PARTY.
WHY THEY SEW DIVISION, WHY THEY
NEED THE THEMES OF RACISM TO
STAY ALIVE.
GUESS WHAT, THE BLACK COMMUNITY
IS WAKING UP.
THAT'S WHY KANYE WEST TERRIFIES
THEM.
HE'S NOT SCARED IN THE SAME WAY
I'M NOT SCARED.
WE SEE MORE BLACK CONSERVATIVES
WAKING UP AND SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST DEMOCRAT PARTY.
>> Sean: I HAVE A HANNITY
CRYSTAL BALL.
WHAT I SEE IN MY FUTURE ARE
AMAZING FUTURES FOR BOTH OF YOU,
WITH STRONG LEADERSHIP AND JUST